Professor Amy
Hungerford: Let me ask you a
question first about John Barth
and the stories that I asked you
to read.
Which of them was your favorite?
Some cackling I hear.
None of them?
Which of them was your
favorite?Student:
"Night-Sea Journey."
Professor Amy Hungerford:
"Night-Sea
Journey."
Why?Student:
I thought it was the
profoundest joke I'd ever
read.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Ah ha.
Yes. Okay. Very good. Yes.
'The profoundest joke she has
ever heard."
Who else?
Your favorite story.
Yes.Student:
"Lost in the
Funhouse."Professor Amy
Hungerford: Okay.
Why is that?Student:
I really liked the tricks
that Barth played with
vocabulary.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Uh huh.
Yes.
Okay.
What else?
Other favorites?
Did anyone have "Ambrose His
Mark" as a favorite?
Only one--two of you.
That's extremely surprising.
Why was "Ambrose His Mark" not
your favorite?
What did you not like about it?
Anyone?
Yes.Student:
I actually thought it was
hard to understand,
just what was happening,
the action part of the story.
It might have been that I read
it too quickly.
Professor Amy
Hungerford: Uh huh.
Harder than "Menelaiad"
to
understand?Student:
No.Professor Amy
Hungerford: No.
Oh.
Okay.
Anyone else on "Ambrose His
Mark"?
Comments?
When I ask this question,
typically, especially when I've
had students read the whole
thing, "Ambrose His Mark" is
almost always the favorite
story.
And the reason for that,
I think, is that it is a
technically perfect short story.
It has wit;
it has developed characters;
it has a coherent narrative.
Even if it has some
difficulties,
that's probably more due to
things like dialect.
There's a German immigrant
dialect that some of the
characters speak.
It's full of little tropes,
little consistencies,
little images,
the bees, even the word play,
"skep" and "skeptical."
There are words that mirror
some of the major themes of that
story about naming.
Barth, by offering us a perfect
short story in that story,
is demonstrating what
traditional structures of
narrative have always offered
us.
And the fact that it's not your
favorite…maybe we're at a
watershed moment,
that even traditional narrative
can just…you guys are so
well beyond that seduction.
Maybe it's Lolita that
we read.
Maybe it's that you got so
seduced by Lolita,
or you were so well trained
to be skeptical of narrative
seduction,
that now nothing can faze you,
nothing can seduce you.
Maybe that's it.
Give yourself that credit.
John Barth is a teacher,
through and through.
He actually taught at my alma
mater, Johns Hopkins,
for over thirty years,
in the writing program.
And I once got from him a
handout that he would give to
his fiction classes,
and it had on it all the
traditional tricks and
structures of the short story
form.
It was three or four pages
single-spaced,
typed: things like,
"if there are five pistols
hanging on the wall,
by the end of the story,
they all have to go off," these
totally structural observations
about how to write a piece of
short fiction.
It's so appropriate:
in my various moves in my life,
I lost this piece of paper,
and I have never been able to
find it.
And I've tried to be in touch
with him about it,
and I couldn't get it from him
either.
So, this is one of the sad
things about teaching Barth for
me.
He was such a teacher.
I think this story collection
is very much a teaching of us
about narrative.
I'm sorry that I can't now
produce that,
as your teacher,
for you.
I want to do something that
might seem odd as I begin.
Does this shock anyone?
Do you have a visceral sense,
"oh, don't do that"?
If you do, you were probably
taught, like me:
"never, never damage a book."
Getting in trouble:
in our house if you damaged a
book you were in big trouble.
Okay.
So, what I'm doing is,
I'm taking the mobius strip
from the beginning,
and I am matching the letters
here,
capital A--let's see how does
it go--capital A overlaps with
small A, capital B overlaps with
small B,
tape it together.
Okay.
There we go.
"Once upon a time there was a
story that began once upon a
time there was a story that
began once upon a time."
Okay.
So, you get the point.
Why does Barth put this in the
front of his story?
Well, I think there are
several reasons,
and I'm going to name about
three of them.
One is that language is
material.
I think we have a visceral
response, sometimes,
when you cut a book,
because somehow we don't want
to be reminded that a story is
in a material container.
But he invites us to do this to
his story.
So, that's the first point:
It's material.
The second point is that
narrative has a form,
and that it can be constructed,
built.
It's like a craft.
I had my little tape and my
little scissors,
my little project,
my craft project.
So, stories are a craft.
They get built of the material
of language.
Last point: form is both
endless and closed.
It is both repetitious and
endlessly filled with
possibility.
Because, when you read this in
its mobius strip form,
you're repeating a beginning
over and over and over again,
it gives you that feeling of
possibility, but it's also
boring.
This is not an interesting
story.
It doesn't tell us anything.
John Barth runs a certain
kind of risk in this story
collection, and it's the risk of
difficulty.
If I had had you read the whole
thing, you would see even more
the kind of risk he's running.
Some of the stories are
self-consciously,
boringly metafictional.
They sound like all those
stories we have about somebody
writing a story about
themselves,
about themselves writing a
story who is also writing a
story about themselves writing a
story.
It's very boring.
There's no kind of life in it.
It's all about that endless
regress.
So, Barth is taking a risk that
this little craft project
emphasizes and that the stories
in the book act out.
Why is it worth it to him to
take that risk?
What's he trying to teach us
about narrative and about
language that makes it worth
this risk?
Now, let me just make the
last point I want to make about
this, and that's that because
language is material,
it has form,
it has both closedness and
possibility, it's susceptible to
the workings of craft,
it's also unpredictable.
What's going to happen to that
now?
Who's going to find it?
It's going to sit there.
It's going to blow from place
to place.
Again, in other stories that I
didn't have you read,
the theme of the message in the
bottle returns over and over
again.
The sense that language is
material means that it can be
separate from people and have a
kind of life of its own.
Now, one question for us is:
is the life of its own that
Barth dreams of for language
similar to that life of its own
that Nabokov dreamed of for his
language?
So, that's a question I want
you to keep in your mind.
Is this the same dream,
or is it somehow different?
So, I'm going to leave that
there.
And maybe some--I don't
know--some chemistry class will
show up in here,
and someone will wonder what
that is,
and Barth will have done his
work, or we will have done
Barth's work for him.
Now, let me ask you another
question.
Who is the narrator of
"Night-Sea Journey"?
Student:
A sperm?Professor
Amy Hungerford:
Yes.
A sperm.
Did everyone get that?
No.
Okay.
The narrator of "Night-Sea
Journey" is a sperm.
Now, why have a story with a
sperm as a narrator?
Well, I think there are a
couple of points,
a couple of reasons why Barth
wants to do that,
and actually related to your
initial point about why you
liked this, that it was-- how
did you say that?--it was the
most--Student:
Profound
joke--Professor Amy
Hungerford: Profound joke.
It is a parody of all the
meanings of life that philosophy
has offered up to us over the
ages,
so it kind of runs through them
in the voice of our narrator
sperm's pal, who is now gone and
dead before him.
So, we get a kind of wisdom in
a parodic form.
There are other points,
however, and if you look on
page 4 we can see just a little
example of one of them.
This sperm has gained quite a
vocabulary, and it includes this
line: "I have seen the best
swimmers of my generation go
under."
Now, where is that from?
Of course it's from
Howl: "I have seen the
best minds of my
generation…."
The point of making a sperm who
quotes not only Allen Ginsberg,
but also hosts of other prior
literary texts,
is the point that the tradition
precedes the individual speaker.
The individual speaker believes
that he has an original voice.
He believes he's speaking in
his own voice,
but, lo and behold,
his words are not his own.
So, just as this is a redaction
and a compression of all the
various meanings of life that
Western philosophy has offered
up,
it is also a demonstration of
how literary tropes,
literary language,
little packaged bits of
literature,
quotations, allusions,
lard the language that is
available to this creature.
His final reflections on page
12 suggest his ambition as a
speaker, and it looks a lot like
a modernist ambition.
The bottom of page 12:
What has fetched me
across this dreadful sea is a
single hope, gift of my poor
dead comrade:
that You may be stronger-willed
than I,
and that by sheer force of
concentration I may transmit to
You, along with Your official
Heritage,
a private legacy of awful
recollection and negative
resolve.
Mad as it may be,
my dream is that some
unimaginable embodiment of
myself (or myself plus Her if
that's how it must be) will come
to find itself expressing,
in however garbled or radical a
translation, some reflection of
these reflections.
It's a dream of changing the
tradition, of having that
individual voice added to the
tradition,
to have it become part of the
official heritage and yet at
odds with it,
casting a different light back.
This is precisely that
modernist dream specifically
articulated by T.S.
Eliot in "Tradition and the
Individual Talent" that the
contribution of the individual
adds to and changes the
tradition in one swoop.
Is this going to be Barth's
ambition, too?
This is a question for us,
again, that I want to,
kind of, keep up on the shelf
in your mind.
In some way it's a parody of
that modernist effort,
when it comes in the voice of a
sperm, because this whole story
is a parody.
So, you have to ask that
question and be somewhat
skeptical.
For all that Barth looks like,
he embodies that traditional
modernist ambition of
difficulty, of working with
tradition and so on.
He looks like a classic late
modernist, but is he,
really?
This is the question.
"Ambrose His Mark"
purports to be the story of
the birth of that being when the
sperm from "Night-Sea
Journey" is united with
the egg.
So, this is Ambrose's
conception that we see the
preamble to.
And in "Ambrose His Mark,"
if you look on page 19,
you will see that Ambrose has,
in some sense,
inherited some aspect of that
sperm's remarkable linguistic
facility.
He says: "All that
winter…."
This is the middle of the page:
All that winter,
as I grew in mother's womb,
grandfather fretted with his
scheme [to get Willie Erdmann's
bees];
when the spring's first bees
appeared on our pussy willows,
on our alder catkins,
he was off with Hector and
Konrad, saucepan and
cheesecloth.
Their researches led them
through fresh-marsh,
through pine-woods,
over stile and under
trestle--but never a bee-tree
they discovered,
only swampy impasses or the
hives of some part-time
apiarist.
He's narrating in great detail
what happened while he was in
the womb.
Where does this knowledge come
from?
It's as if his knowledge of his
own conception,
his own birth,
his own babyhood,
is a natural knowledge.
But we must know that it had to
come from someone,
from someone telling stories.
The stories then become part of
Ambrose's own account of his own
naming, an account of the origin
of his identity.
That name, "Ambrose His Mark,"
is a reference to Moby-Dick.
In Moby-Dick,
when Queequeg signs on to
the Pequod, he makes a mark,
because he is illiterate,
in place of writing his name,
signing his name,
and in the novel it says
"Queequeg,
his mark."
That's what's written
underneath it on the contract.
With that mark Queequeg signs
on to the whole trajectory of
Ahab's mad pursuit of the whale.
We can think of that in another
way, as well,
though.
With that mark,
Queequeg signs on to the whole
trajectory of the
nineteenth-century novel,
that whole narrative excess
that Melville offers,
and that whole sense of destiny
that is bound up with Ahab's
story.
What does Ambrose sign up for
with his mark?
Well, the first thing to notice
is that, unlike Queequeg,
he does not sign that mark.
The mark, here,
is what he's marked by,
not what he marks with.
And so, it's as if the whole
tradition comes out and grabs
him and names him.
And so, Uncle Karl's efforts to
interpret the incident of the
bee and its relation to the mark
on his face suggests the way
that certain kinds of
tradition--that Uncle Karl has
been reading,
probably in the Book of
Knowledge encyclopedia that
he sells door to door (he's a
sort of scholarly guy)--that
that tradition has named him.
He has no agency in this
trajectory he's entering upon.
The effort to take the
story of his birth and tell it
as if it were natural knowledge
is the effort to fight against
that lack of agency.
He takes those stories and he
makes them his own.
That's an effort at gaining
control over what he cannot know
about his own origin and what he
cannot choose in his own origin.
I think that's also why Barth
chose to write this story in the
perfect short story form.
And that form is also given to
us in Lost in the
Funhouse, on page 95,
when we get the diagram of
Freitag's Triangle.
So, if you look at it here on
95, we're told in the course of
the story about Ambrose and
Magda and the family:
The action of
conventional dramatic narrative
may be represented by a diagram
called Freitag's Triangle:
A,
B, C--[And remember those are
the letters from the mobius
strip as well]--or more
accurately by a variant of that
diagram,
A, B, C, D, with A,
B representing the
exposition…
[and so on and so forth.]
If you read on down in that
paragraph, you will see that
Ambrose in his frustration--in
his effort to control the story
that is always,
in this story,
spinning out of control--he
wants to be able to use
Freitag's Triangle to prop up
what has become an
uncontrollable narrative and
give it a shape.
He retells…even
from one sentence to the next,
he changes his mind.
He says, "This can't go on much
longer.
It can go on forever."
He died telling stories to
himself in the dark."
He's dreaming about what will
happen to him in the funhouse.
.
years later when that vast
suspected area of the funhouse
came to light,
the first expedition found his
skeleton in one of its
labyrinthine corridors and
mistook it for a part of the
entertainment.
He died of starvation telling
himself stories in the dark;
but unbeknownst,
unbeknownst to him,
an assistant operator of the
funhouse, happening to overhear
him,
crouched just behind the
plyboard partition and wrote
down every word.
The operator's daughter,
an exquisite young woman with a
figure unusually well developed
for her age,
crouched just behind the
partition and transcribed his
every word.
He changes the story from one
sentence to the next.
Freitag's Triangle won't help
him at all.
So, just knowing the form that
the story is supposed to take,
and then knowing that language
has grabbed you,
all these formulaic little
phrases, "a figure unusually
well developed for her age,"
these little stock phrases.
They are what he has to work
with, even though they are what
defeat him in his effort to make
sense of this experience with
Magda.
And it is the experience
with Magda that produces the
problem in the first place.
And so, if we look at page 84,
you can see the,
sort of, primal scene of this
problem.
This is when he and Magda were
having a sort of erotic game one
summer in the shed.
They were playing slaves and
masters, and he was the master,
and she was the slave.
So, he's imagining their future
and talking about it with Magda
when they're older.
I'm going to start sort of in
the middle of the page.
He would be quite famous
in his line of work.
Whether Magda was his wife or
not, one evening when he was
wise-lined and gray at the
temples he'd smile gravely,
at a fashionable dinner party,
and remind her of his youthful
passion.
The time they went with his
family to Ocean City;
the erotic fantasies he
used to have about her.
How long ago it seemed and
childish!
Yet tender too,
n'est-ce pas?
[That's a Humbert moment.
That's Humbert.]
Would she have imagined that
the world famous whatever
remembered how many strings were
on the lyre on the bench beside
the girl on the label of the
cigar box he'd stated at in the
tool shed at age ten while she,
age eleven.
Even then, he had felt wise
beyond his years;
[Another stock phrase.]
he'd stroked her hair and said
in his deepest voice and
correctest English,
as to a dear child,
"I shall never forget this
moment."
But though he had breathed
heavily, groaned as if ecstatic,
what he'd really felt
throughout was an odd detachment
as though someone else were
Master.
Strive as he might to be
transported, he had heard his
mind take notes upon the scene:
This is what they call
passion.
I am experiencing it.
Many of the digger machines
were out of order in the penny
arcades and could not be
repaired or replaced for the
duration.
Moreover, the prizes,
made now in
U.S.A….
It goes off in this strange
digression.
It seems like his mind has
simply wandered,
as it does, from one version of
the story to another.
But the mention of the machines
is not incidental.
Narrative becomes a kind of
machine.
You put your penny in the slot
and it works to produce the
narrative.
And that's that first part that
I read, where he's looking back
fondly with Magda from his
eminence,
later in life,
and it seems safely past and
something that can be talked
about.
But the problem is that,
even if he could produce that
kind of comforting narrative,
the problem it produced at the
level of identity will never be
repaired.
Self-alienation,
in Barth's work,
is the product of desire.
Desire, love:
that's the moment when you're
supposed to be perfectly
present.
And what happens to Ambrose?
That's the moment when he is
perfectly, distressingly
alienated from himself.
And, it's the moment when
language comes in and is the
product of that alienation,
or perhaps when language comes
in and causes that alienation.
So, he can't experience an
erotic moment without also
experiencing it through the
screen of language,
and what he ends up doing is
experiencing language instead of
sex.
So, this is the problem that's
never solved in Lost in the
Funhouse, and it has
all kinds of ramifications.
This is on 83,
just the page before.
Remember, this whole story
takes place under the aegis of
his alienation from himself.
He's thinking about what he'd
like to do in the funhouse.
If you knew your way
around in the funhouse like your
own bedroom, you could wait
until a girl came along and then
slip away without ever getting
caught,
even if her boyfriend was right
with her.
She'd think he did it!
It would be better to be the
boyfriend, and act outraged,
and tear the funhouse apart.
Not act;
be.
"He's a master diver," Ambrose
said.
In feigned admiration.
"You really have to slave away
at it to get that good."
He's playing with Freudian
slips.
Of course, what he's thinking
about all the time is the
master-slave game,
and so here it comes out,
when he's talking about his
brother's diving:
"He's a master diver.
You really have to slave away
at it."
He can't control the emergence
of his desire,
his memory of the desire,
back into his daily speech.
So, he can't control that
Freudian slip,
and he also has to correct
himself,
remind himself,
that what he wants to do in the
funhouse is actually not act
like the outraged boyfriend
but be the outraged
boyfriend.
This is always the problem for
Ambrose.
He can't just be something;
he is always conscious of
inhabiting a performance.
And it's usually a verbal
performance.
These are the problems that
plague Menelaus so
terribly in that final story
that I asked you to read.
So, one of the problems with
narrative, I said earlier when
we talked about the mobius
strip, is that it's repetition.
This suggests a kind of
exhaustion of language and
Ambrose's use of these packaged
phrases in Lost in the
Funhouse suggests the
impossibility of using all that
tradition,
all that stock of language,
to adequately encounter what
daily life will bring you,
and especially to adequately
inhabit something like desire.
Barth wrote a famous essay just
the year before these stories
came out all in one volume.
They had been written over a
series of years,
about five years,
in the '60s.
And he wrote a very famous
essay--got a lot of
exposure--called "The Literature
of Exhaustion."
And there,
he criticized a lot of the work
that was being done,
and these are the terms he
uses.
He said there were two kinds of
artists: ones who are
"technically up to date," and
ones that are not.
Those who are not write
turn of the century-type
novels, only in more or less mid
twentieth-century language and
about contemporary people and
topics.
This makes them less
interesting to me than excellent
writers who are also technically
contemporary,
Joyce and Kafka,
for instance,
in their time,
and in ours Samuel Beckett and
Jorge Luis Borges.
What exhausts language is
the failure to keep technically
up to date, and that means in
innovation in form.
"Menelaiad" is where
Barth really stakes his claim
for innovation:
those nested layers of
narrative that are so
off-putting on the page that I
have to send you a handout to
help you over the weekend.
(Otherwise I worry that people
will be really lost.) It's very
off-putting, but it's precisely
those nested stories that allow
him to do some of the really
pleasurable things that he can
do in that story and,
I would say,
get at some of the very deep
questions raised by the earlier
stories that he finally,
kind of, gets hold of (to use
his own words) in this last
story.
So, I want to begin by
thinking about Menelaus's
predicament with Helen,
and this is on 146.
So, he spares Helen's life in
Troy and brings her home,
and this is the story that he
has been telling.
So, he says,
"I decided that I would spare
her life and accept her
groveling for forgiveness
instead."
So, this is the story he's
telling himself:.
.
I forbore, resolved to accept
in lieu of her death a modest
portion of heartfelt grovel.
Further, once she'd flung
herself at my knees and kissed
my hem I would order her supine
and mount more as one who loves
than one who conquers;
not impossibly,
should she acquit herself well
and often, I would even
entertain a plea for her
eventual forgiveness and
restoration to the Atrean house.
Accordingly I drew myself up to
discharge her
objection--whereupon she gave
over cleaning her nails and set
to drumming them on one knee.
""""""Let your repentance
salt my shoe leather," I said
presently, "and then,
as I lately sheathed my blade
of anger, so sheath you my blade
of love."
"""""I only just came
aboard," she replied.
"I haven't unpacked yet."
""""With a roar I went
up the companionway,
dashed stern to stem,
close-hauled the main,
flogged a smile from my
navigator, and clove us through
the pastures of the squid.
Leagues thereafter,
when the moon changed phase I
overtook myself,
determined shrewdly that her
Troy chests were secured,
and vowing this time to grant
the trull no quarter,
at the second watch of night
burst into her cubby and forgave
her straight out.
"Of the unspeakable we'll speak
no further," I declared.
"I here extend to you what no
other in my position would:
my outright pardon."
To which, some moments after,
I briskly appended:
"Disrobe and receive,
it for the sake of pity!
This offer won't stand forever."
[And of course there are lots
of phallic jokes here,
so I hope you're getting
those.]
There I had her;
she yawned and responded:
"It's late.
I'm tired."
""""Up the mast half a
dozen times I stormed and
shinnied, took oar to my
navigator,
lost sight of Nestor,
thundered and lightninged
through Poseidon's finny fief.
When next I came to season,
I stood a night slyly by while
she dusk-to-dawned it,
then saluted with this
challenge her opening eyes:
"Man born of woman is
imperfect.
On the three thousand two
hundred eighty-seventh night of
your Parisian affair,
as I lay in Simois-mud picking
vermin off the wound I got that
day from cunning Pandarus,
exhaustion closed my eyes.
I dreamed myself was pretty
Paris, plucked by Aphrodite from
the field and dropped into
Helen's naked lap.
There we committed sweet
adultery;
I woke wet, wept. . ."
""""Here I paused in my
fiction to shield my eyes and
stanch the arrow-straight tracks
clawed down my cheek.
Then, as one who'd waited
precisely for her maledict voice
to hoarsen, I outshouted her in
these terms: "Therefore come to
bed,
my equal, uncursing,
uncursed!"
""""The victory was mine,
I still believe,
but when I made to take trophy,
winded Helen shook her head,
declaring, "I have the curse."
[She has her period.]
""""My taffrail oaths
took Triton's stamp-ground;
I fed to the fish my navigator,
knocked my head against the
mast and others;
hollered up a gale that blew us
from Laconic Melea to Egypt.
My crew grew restive;
when the storm was spent and I
had done flogging me with
halyard, I chose a moment
somewhere off snakèd
Libya,
slipped my cloak,
rapped at Helen's cabin,
and in measured tones declared:
"Forgive me."
Adding firmly:
"Are you there?"
He's pathetic!
He runs through all these
stories about himself,
and as each one fails to win
him back into Helen's cabin,
he comes up with another one.
This is a certain kind of
exhausted narrative.
It's the failure of any of
these stock narratives to have
the effect of restoring love and
desire, but it's more than that.
It's playful.
It's funny.
Barth's effort at showing us
the exhaustion of narrative
produces a kind of new pleasure
in narrative.
So it's by pointing it out,
and then parodying it,
that he begins to renew the
resources of fiction.
There are deeper and more
difficult issues at stake,
though, and this is in 155.
We get a more serious version
of the scene with Magda and the
problem of self-alienation.
And this is what is really at
the heart of Menelaus's story.
So, remember that the story is
that he is obsessed with this
question of why Helen chose him
among all her suitors:
why did she choose him?
And, when he asks on their
wedding night,
she gives him an answer that
only makes him more obsessed
with the question.
So, at the top of 155,
he's asked his question.
"'Speak,' he commanded.
She whispered, 'Love.'"
Now, the problem with that is
that answer;
it's a verb and a noun.
And Menelaus doesn't know how
to take it, so here it becomes a
verb:
He held her fast;
she took him willy-nilly to her;
I feel her yet,
one endless instant,
Menelaus was no more,
never has been since.
This is like that moment of
erotic play with Magda for
Ambrose.
It eradicates identity,
eradicates sense of self.
It's gone forever,
and you can see the change in
pronouns.
"She took him willy-nilly to
her."
He's telling a story about
himself, seemingly,
but who is the "I," then,
that's left over?
"I feel her yet."
There is some residual identity
left over that can still have a
sense of embodiment.
.
In his red ear then she
whispered, "Why'd I wed you?"
Less what than who,
et cetera?"""""
"""My very
question."
"""""""Speak," Menelaus
cried to Helen on the bridal
bed," I reminded Helen in her
Trojan bedroom,"
I confessed to Eidothea on the
beach," I declared to Proteus in
the cave-mouth,"
I vouchsafed to Helen on the
ship," I told Peisistratus at
least in my Spartan hall,"
I say to whoever and where- I
am and Helen answered:
"""""""Love."""""""
!
""""""He complied.
He complied as to an order.
She took his corse once more to
Elysium, to fade forever among
the fadeless asphodel;
his curious fancy alone
remained unlaid;
when he came to himself it
still asked softly:
"why?""""""".
And don't I cry out to me
every hour since.
.
So, that self-alienation causes
him to lose his love.
We're told later that he stops
sleeping with her because he
just can't get it out of his
mind.
He'd rather sit and wonder.
His curious fancy is more
active than his desire.
Or, you might say,
his desire to know is more
active than his desire to love.
But there is yet a complication
to this problem.
It's not just about Menelaus
and what he chooses to do with
his desire.
It's also about Helen and her
action and her answer.
On 156 he reflects.
Seven years of this,
more or less,
not much conversation,
something wrong with the
marriage.
Helen he could hold;
how hold Menelaus?
To love is easy;
to be loved as if one were
real, on the order of others:
fearsome mystery!
Unbearable responsibility!
To her Menelaus
signified something
recognizable,
as Helen to him.
Whatever was it?
There is that sense that the
other person looking at you,
loving you, assures you somehow
of your reality,
that you're real,
that you're not an imaginary
being.
So, it's a way of reminding you
that you're not really
alienated, but this is what
Menelaus cannot get his head
around.
He cannot understand that he
could be loved for no reason and
Proteus sort of gives us a sense
of how we could understand this.
This is on 161.
Helen chose you without
reason because she loves you
without cause;
embrace her without question
and watch your weather change.
Let go.
It's a failure of faith in
Aphrodite.
So, to accept love is to accept
your being and to have faith
that love affirms it,
affirms that being.
Remember that self-admonition:
not act like the
boyfriend but be.
This is what Menelaus has to
ask forgiveness for.
He didn't have enough faith in
love just to be and to accept
the affirmation of his being
that Helen's reasonless,
causeless love embodies.
Barth is asking a really
serious question about the
compatibility between life and
voice.
Remember that in "Ambrose His
Mark" Ambrose is saved
from the bees lighting on his
mouth because his mouth is on
his mother's breast.
He's asleep there having nursed.
It's as if the bees which
signify eloquence if they land
on your mouth,
they land on his eyes and on
his ears instead.
He can't have both that
connection with his mother and
that kind of eloquence.
It's one or the other.
You can't have love and
language somehow,
and this is a very Freudian
understanding of how language
works.
He tells a story about a child
playing what's called the
"Fort-Da" game:
here, away.
He has a little ball.
A little two- or three-year-old
kid has a ball.
He throws it away and then
retrieves it,
he throws it away and retrieves
it, and Freud theorizes that he
does that and he says,
"Fort, da, fort,
da."
He does that because the
language is a way of controlling
his mother's absence and the
ball stands in for the mother.
It disappears and then it comes
back.
It disappears and comes back,
and at that time his mother,
who is actually Freud's
daughter,
was going out to work for the
first time on some days,
and the boy was getting used to
letting her go.
So, language arises from
that loss.
And Ambrose is only named once
he's separated from his mother
and no longer nurses as a result
of the bee incident,
and he also only gains a male
name at that time.
And so, I think it's important
that the masculinity of language
asserted with a talking sperm at
the very beginning of this
collection is consistent with
this sense that you become male
when you enter into language.
Somehow when you're unnamed
you're not part of language;
you're still connected to the
mother.
And he actually had a female
name.
Remember he's called Christine
for a while.
So he becomes a boy after he's
separated from his mother.
Menelaus's problem with Helen
suggests that incompatibility of
being connected to the other,
and here across the line of
gender, connected with the other
and somehow being able to be
assimilated into language,
and the silence of the oracle
on the question,
"Who am I?"
This is on 158,
and you just get that blank,
silence, and you can see it
enclosed in all those quotation
marks.
This is Barth's effort to
enclose the silence into
something readable,
to contain that impossibility
in the structure of the story.
So all the quotation marks
suggest human voice.
I want to suggest to you
finally that Barth is interested
in the oral tradition above all
other traditions in this book.
He's using Greek epic as the
source of his literary canon,
here, and his canon of stories,
of narratives,
because it's oral tradition
that brings the human voice and
the human being,
the fact of a person,
together most closely.
That's what fascinates him
about the spoken word,
as opposed to the word you
read.
And in other stories in this
collection Barth experimented
with recording them with tape.
So, these are stories,
some of them for voice and
tape, and he'd do readings where
he'd go and he'd put a tape
recorder on the podium and he'd
stand next to the tape recorder
as his voice read the story from
the tape recorder.
And it was all to dramatize the
problematic relationship between
voice, story and person.
But I think the dream of
Menelaus is that somehow that
voice can be residual,
that somehow it can survive.
And, in that sense,
I think it has something in
common with Nabokov's fantasy of
the living artwork.
But, unlike Nabokov's fantasy,
it requires this concept of
love, because love is what makes
being into narrative.
It takes two,
and it takes desire.
Desire moves narrative.
And so at the end,
the comic ending of
"Menelaiad," which echoes
the comic ending of Odysseus'
trip back home,
of The Odyssey,
he says:
Menelaus's story itself
in ten or ten thousand years
expires, yet I'll survive it
[Who is this "I"?],
I, in Proteus's terrifying last
disguise, Beauty" spouse"s,
odd Elysium:
the absurd,
unending possibility of
love.
If you think that Barth in all
his heady, intellectual,
canonical difficulty is
uninterested in the world
outside of his fiction,
I think you could argue that
it's on this notion of desire
that he stakes his work's
connection to the world.
And the echo of that desire is,
I would say,
pleasure: something like,
in this case,
Nabokov's aesthetic bliss,
but here it's more funny than
that.
It's not even so much the
transportation and the nostalgic
quality of Nabokov's
description, sometimes.
It's that wit,
that pleasurable wit,
the pleasure we get reading,
being absorbed by something
that we have to work hard to
read,
and yet repays us with that
pleasure.
When you read Crying of Lot
49 I'd like you to think
about what that novel represents
in the relation between language
and the world.
Is it similar?
Barth and Pynchon are often
talked about as part of the same
metafictional movement in this
couple of decades,
'60s and '70s.
Are they assimilable to one
another in these terms?
Think about that as you read.